I bet you have a great idea that you can
probably turn into reality and you can
with Squarespace and make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project do
you want to showcase work do you want to
sell products of any kind they got you
covered with beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
you can easily make a beautiful website
all by yourself but if you do get stuck
happens to the best of us Squarespace is
24/7 award-winning customer support is
there to help so head to squarespace.com
slash grace for a free trial and when
you are ready to launch you go at your
own pace use the offer code grace to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain hello welcome to
another episode of not too deep I am
your host grace and helping the first
very great lovely high-energy super fun
episode lies ahead for you guys we have
young easy and Natalie Odell they're so
sweet so fun so funny if you don't know
them you're gonna know them by the end
of this we learn all about the how they
met via you wouldn't believe it
Instagram how they became best friends
and how they've recently fallen in love
love love not like fake prank
click bake video love like real human to
human love and ides very sweet and
they're just so lovely we talk about all
the tips that you need to create a
social media career and some of the
pranks that they've pulled on each other
that have gone too far one involved an
entire snake just a big old giant cobra
snake in a bedroom not in a place where
snakes should be ever but yet they're
still in love can you believe it enjoy
this episode of not too deep with
Natalie Odell and young easy
[Music]
first of all I want to know how are you
ladies doing in quarantine right now
because for you know creators we've all
had to adapt but looking at everything
looking at your social media you're very
very busy both of you are you're doing
and producing so much stuff that I'm
tired on your behalf just keeping up
with all of it like what have you how
have you been what have you been up to
stop everybody everybody
but then again everybody's like y'all
soon as we drop something that the
hunger level has increased good no I
mean it's a the amount of content that
you guys are producing is incredible but
I can see that there's so much going on
with you guys that everyone wants more
and more and more and I feel like unless
you're live streaming 24 hours a day
it's not enough for people okay I want
to get into all of it but first let me
go back to the beginning I'd like to
hear both of your perspectives on your
origin story the first time you guys met
each other what was that story okay so
my birdly you know she brought me on
instagram and you know I had already
seen her before she didn't have his
emini as many followers but I had seen
her because she was collaborating with a
lot of big influencers you know but I
never reached out to her but I just seen
her around
no social media or paper stuff like that
oh okay cool but at the time I had never
collaborated you know and I always
confuse
I didn't know how that process work had
all these fours or whatever brown like
getting these connections like they do
you know right right
I built it on my own so it was just like
me and I'm like oh and I was scared of
rejection I'm a Maori shopping somebody
so uh but so when she reached out to me
to message means she said you know hey
you want to collab and I see my message
you know so I was okay it was like I
think a couple hours later and then she
you know she finally was fronting this
crazy cool idea and I was like yo that's
cool she was not way in Miami I was in
California and it was like how are we
gonna do this so she came away to do it
virtually and maybe it looks still good
and it was like wow and then she ended
up coming out here from my perspective
it was like you know like she keeps
inviting me to everything around all
these using influences and my due date
influencers bigger than me you're gonna
hurt I'm like how does she know why does
she keep inviting she's so freaking cool
yeah and ever since then we just became
inseparable it was just like we formed
this cool friendship it was like just
amazing amazing things you know progress
in the last video so now let's how
what's the time frame on this how long
ago was it that you first met each other
so we first met 2016 yes okay 2016 we
first met basically from my perspective
[Music]
I was collaborating with a lot of people
because I basically came to LA to act
and I didn't live here yet I was just
and I happened to meet some really big
influencers at the time I mean their
silver it was a king bass and a storm
and all of them I ran into them they
ended up filming with me unless I
started growing like really mad and I
start becoming friends with like
everybody you know and I was like you
know when I go home I'm still going to
reach out to influencers all the time
and I'm gonna be creative on how I can
collaborate so I saw her and I was like
she's funny I think perfect it's a
little bit different than mine but I
think we could do something together so
that's when I reached out terms like hey
you wanna collab I would literally do
this every day to tons of people like
yeah you know like she said I was
collaborating with everybody right so
when I basically wrote her I told her I
had a good idea I didn't expect that she
was gonna respond that quick because she
has so many followers like immediately
to like even respond back with the ideas
because I had to come up with my god she
was like uh yes creative idea I had one
um give me one second here it is exactly
so then basically you know we shot the
idea but even before we shot the idea we
had a FaceTime call and we talked for
hours and clicked
yeah immediately we just clicked and I
was just like oh she's so cool you know
she had a girlfriend at the time and
stuff and she was like her girlfriends
jealous because you know when the
girlfriends jealous that's how you know
we just like innocent innocent like you
know totally I had never even looked at
a girl like I don't like anything
anxiety it was nothing but then you know
basically built to me moving out here
and we became like best friends like
instantly yes yeah you guys you have a
chemistry that you really can't fake you
know it's and I'm sure people comment
this all the time that like it feels
very real it feels like you guys have
known each other your entire lives and
that's just really fun to watch so I
want to hear a little bit about how each
of you got into doing stuff online doing
the social media like what is your what
are your backgrounds so for me you know
my background is acting so like I said
when I came to LA I was actually coming
to network for acting at first and this
was back in 2015 and then I met people
in social media and I felt like okay
this is still acting like it might not
be me going on casting calls and then I
end up quickly realizing that people are
making a real living on but this and
it's actually giving people
opportunities to get their foot in the
door for other things like acting well
that's how I got into it and I just
stuck with it yeah I got into it
literally like ever since I was a kid I
loved like recording but my grandma got
me a camcorder so I like to actually
show your grandma got you a camcorder
yeah that's a great grandma like that's
very cool awesome almost I begged her
for years and years she finally got me
one a v8 I like being test takes to put
this is how you act know that you know a
director I didn't I was directing but it
was just like I love telling people what
to do and you can make it come to life
you know so once I did that and it was
just like I found a love for it I like
being more behind the camera in front of
it but one social media like hey you
know it was Instagram when they came old
videos was fine and stuff like that
I made a cool funny video I've always
been funny in Carl's town and stuff so I
made a funny video anyway viral or
whatever and I was like yo like I always
wanted to be acting and stuff like that
but I guess I can do this you know
people are gonna love this so I just
stuck with it and just did like
different versions of myself and funny
videos and I'm kind of like you know
gained a huge fall and I loved it ever
since and I loved entertaining people
and making people smile so it just stops
them that's very good and it's one of
those things that it's you know hard to
put into words exactly how because it's
very difficult to have something go
viral and then to maintain and grow
nicely from there so what was your
experience with that cuz it's kind of
like an oh [ __ ] moment there's lots of
eyes on me how do I keep this going
right now right and I think that's what
a lot of people like like you're saying
like that that viral is feeling you have
to learn how to capitalize on them this
is what we teach everybody in our book
yeah capitalizing off of that viral
moment is so important because I know
this okay so the video was pretty much
like you know I'm part of the LGBTQ
community and it was like you know how
how lesbians act and I was dressed up on
tomboy but when the club says Lady Shri
before Tim I dressed like a girl so I
was like a Swiss yeah I know and then I
was okay people love me embracing you
know my community and on top of they
still see me like dress girl because I
never just girly so how do I incorporate
that and then still so I just stuck with
the like talking about the LGBT
community but making it so funny
you know so basically to break it down
that was how she did it but to break it
down for just anyone
it's about identifying like she did what
works for you you know if you end up
going viral before you even really
realize that your brand is and the
message you're trying to put out there
you have to identify why did that go
viral what did people like about a look
at the comments all of that and that's
the type of stuff you stick to I think
that people have a problem with trying
too much or doing too much and a lot of
times that's why they'll see like
something they're successful actually on
what sometimes it's doing good sometimes
it's not - because you're not kind of
like really listening to what the
audience wants to see right right and
you guys do you do a lot of pranks
which kudos I cannot do pranks I am such
a [ __ ]
like I makes me cringe so hard I can't
do it but I have such admiration for
people that are actually able to do it
and to like be in public in the most
ridiculous sense that you guys have put
yourself in is there a favorite that has
stood out to you or one that's been the
most memorable a 250-pound snake in her
bed while she's asleep no thank you no
thank you
how did you okay the logistics of this
for one until you have second largest
one account yes the second largest no I
literally all the hair on my arm is
standing up right now I hate snakes but
okay so you have this first of all how
do you have this idea honestly started I
just would think like all right it's
hardened each other so much you stay
innovative and kind of do something that
they're not going to expect I was like
she's not gonna expect to wake up with
this snake and then you know what she
does wake up with it she's gonna know I
did it but her reactions are gonna be
priceless because she's really bright so
basically I just try to think what are
her biggest fears and she's afraid of
she's literally afraid of little tiny
like daddy longlegs so I knew she'd be
afraid of dismay and I why'd you see the
country girl in the video I'm like how
do you go from I want to get a snake and
put it in her bed to getting the actual
snake and thought I didn't have a lot of
research honestly I just started looking
on even Instagram and being like okay
what zookeeper he's like I was just
looking for somebody to collaborate with
and I found like a guy who has all kinds
pythons and stuff like that was like you
know what let me do
so I wrote him and he was like calm down
so we did it oh my god
now I'd like break it down yeah I'm
telling you everything was blowing my
head you're gonna hear me brought the
snake I was okay you guys have to come
early in the morning because I need to
be up and ready to take in her room
before she's awake so when they got here
and they bring that I didn't even really
fathom how big the snake was gonna be
when they brought it out it was in like
one of the big tugs with the little seal
a huge and it's a who men to lift the
tub out of the truck I was like oh my
god shaking waiting for me to open and
show me this makes icer against here
they open this thing is gigantic it's
like this big like like literally like
this no no it's like tremors no no thank
you
like what oh yeah this could go very
very bad and mind you my bed has been on
the floor since I moved in my house
because I don't know I never
prioritizing we're filming my bed broke
and I was okay whatever it's on the
floor just keep that in mind that my bed
is on the floor once you bringing this
naked I was like it took me a while to
even handle the snake myself but they
bring the snake in and they I are I set
up the camera first in her room and I
told them to like quietly bring sneaking
they bring the sinking and we shut the
door not hold it shut what is that like
it was Scalia what is that and
immediately I jump up I know if I should
stay still or I was sliding you off of
my leg I was literally in the corner
like
oh no sir mom and everything and I
wasn't saving anything outside of the
door oh my god or the snake was like
blocking her and she's and snake starts
going up the wall every play no that's a
nightmare because also you're waking up
so first of all you don't realize like
is this a dream am i still sleeping
right now what is going on oh that's
insane was crazy and the crazy part is
is like after I calmed down like the guy
that brought it in he was like no she's
really sweet I'm like no no for me I
don't care us me it's sweet and it took
me like what couple three hours I think
like I follow me like literally AB they
were there like talking to us they put
it back in the bed and make something so
they just hold it it is kind of sleep
but it was scary but I told I did and I
mean and it didn't ruin your
relationship so no but no I just had to
do something because that's good
mentality that we have and I'm glad that
we're friends like because I know some
friends I can't be certain pranks on
because the friendships alright well
that's it that's that's my other
question too is that you guys you know
you really push the boundaries of your
boundaries with each other and is there
I mean there's obviously a level of
respect that you have for each other
like have you had ideas that you've had
to say actually I can't like that'll be
too much for them we had like I think
three remember we three like we didn't
just put out it was just like okay we'll
shoot something and you're like based on
the reaction that's time and light
depends if we put it out because if the
reaction somebody's no good we actually
get them saying sometimes they have died
upset and it's like alright cuz you got
to mad yeah like I can't even edit
around this to make it look okay right
now it's understandable but it's like
let's just talk about it like maids a
praying and that's what our
communication comes in like really
because it's just like all right even
though we were upset you know and really
really mad yeah yeah well now we're
gonna respect that boundaries putting it
out you know and then talk about it yeah
and I think because we are best friends
we know for so long understanding what
would be absolutely too far yeah no
that's that's very healthy I feel like
that's a much safer space to create and
to like test these content ideas in than
just throwing [ __ ] at the wall and
hoping that they don't get too mad okay
I want to get into you know the
evolution of the relationship and
everything but we're going to take a
quick break when we get back with more
not too deep I have I have so many
questions about this love story okay
we'll be right back with more not too
deep today we have support of course
some Squarespace it's time to turn that
dream of yours into a reality and make
it easier than ever to launch a passion
project you're looking to start a new
business showcase your work published
content sell products or more
Squarespace is the tool for you because
they have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can make a beautiful website
all by yourself they have a powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online and analytics that
help you grow your site in real time and
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box there's nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is super
simple and you can get any help that you
might need with their 24/7 award-winning
customer support they empower millions
of people designers lawyers artists
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas into something real so head
to squarespace.com slash brace for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of the
website or a domain that's
squarespace.com slash grace offer code
grace
too deep right now is the time that all
of us are struggling with some sort of
stress or anxiety or isolation or
depression and you're not alone we're
all going through it and if you're
curious in something that can help you
out better help better help offers
online licensed professional counselors
who can help their counselors specialize
in issues like depression stress anxiety
relationships sleeping trauma anger
family conflicts lgbtq+ matters grief
self-esteem and more you can connect
with your counselor in a safe and
private online environment anything you
share is confidential you fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your needs
and you get matched with a counselor in
less than 24 hours and from there you
can easily schedule secure video or
phone sessions with your therapists plus
exchange unlimited messages I've had
friends that use this app and love it
it's so much especially because you have
the ability to text with your counselor
everything's super confidential and
super convenient to you wherever you are
however you want to communicate and if
for any reason you're unhappy with your
counselor you can request a new one at
any time for no additional charge it's
an affordable option and you guys will
get 10% off your first month of this
already affordable option with the
discount code grace that's better help
btter heelp calm slash grace discount
code grace talk to a therapist online
and get help ok so you guys started your
joint channel you said like at the end
of last year yes and it's really it's so
fun because it how do you describe the
channel it's like a mix of comedy and
reality yeah okay you because you guys
you vlog a lot together and you do
pranks and you have all kinds of fun
ideas I have a hard time and maybe your
audiences too knowing what's real and
what's maybe not yeah I think that's
what I think that's the good thing you
know
like they're you shouldn't be you know
sometimes we do have to tell them like
guys know this is real because of course
like people have their regulation
speculation is this real or is this not
real and stuff but I feel like as long
as you're being like genuine and stuff
when people can really feel when it's
true and they can really tell when we go
from alright we're entertaining you mode
- okay this isn't our relation I
recently transitioned more into it you
know what we want to be more raw with
our audience and not just be
entertaining yeah because we are human
like everybody else you know totally and
that's been the really cool thing
because I mean you guys are what's the
status right now you know and this was
all real right because you did yeah you
did this three-part series in which you
basically told her how you feel about
her and honest and real way which I mean
it's I sat there watching going I can't
believe this is happening I can't
believe this is happening
it's still happening oh my god what's
good yeah and it's yeah I mean that
takes some balls to like one wanna do
that regardless of cameras - yeah put it
on camera so like take me through that
thought process that that was the most
vulnerable I think I've ever been in my
life online you know and that to me was
just like okay the people have already
been wondering I'm gay
you seen the chemistry you know the rain
so people were picking up on this the
feeling that I already had without like
I was like not trying to express it you
don't know saying is like yes my best
friend like why did he have to be a pink
you know I just love her she loves me as
friends you know but at a certain point
it was just like I fell over her you
know anyway I was trying not I did and
it was just like yo people are noticing
and I can't even hide it anymore I can't
even like what I'm looking at her it's
not people in our fan pages will make
clips and stuff like that of just where
they couples how many people were like
making these romance it really did look
like we were together yeah yeah I know
and I was like you know what I need to
be honest with myself if I keep trying
to deny it or if I keep trying to hold
back then I feel like it's also gonna
show because that started to show like
the frustration of me picturing her with
somebody else was showing in some videos
and some videos people will be like yo
are you okay easy people like what's
wrong easy like you know what's going on
and they're not going what's going on
eternally but there really was like two
videos before we played smash or paths
and in that video it was like we started
off like cool at all Grace Matthew or
whatever but then it was just like what
she said like somebody that was actually
really attractive and it could possibly
be I see him slide her diems and she
would be like you know give me a chance
I start putting all that in my head and
I was just like I was tired of feeling
like what is what if I don't make them
move and she's just you know goes for
another guy like I've got to do it happy
I wanted to bring everybody with me and
it's I'm not gonna lie if I would have
got my heart broken I think I don't know
how to put the video ever I mean that's
that's the thing is that it's you posted
all of it so yeah you assume there's
gonna be like a happy ending or
basically it's a very brave thing to put
online regardless of what the answer is
yeah
so did you guys after you filmed some of
it because it is in parts did you kind
of have a discussion off-camera about
like are we really doing this I were
really putting this out there and
explain the day a lot of people confuse
my own the reason why they probably saw
it was raise this favorite plan because
if it was being in multiple parts if you
noticed we had explained or she had
explained that she's like a lot of it
was the same day she just break it up
into separate videos so like her from
her realizing and professing to the
audience that she was in love with me
to coming to tell me she was in love
that was family all the same day oh wow
but the way she wanted to do it was put
it into two separate videos and then he
really did tell me like I could take my
trying to you know decide and stuff and
I don't have to like you know say
anything right now so then I really did
take my time and it was like rough I I
had like family advice like I knew that
I felt something but I couldn't identify
was that like intimate like romantic
love or is that like I love her because
she's my best friend
yeah any yeah off camera I was just
pretty much done or like look cuz even
while we were filming and I left that in
there she asked she's like why are you
so minutes before I asked you the
question and I was like and I told her
like you know I just wanted to be
completely honest and be completely
honest with them and after we filmed
that told her I said you know we don't
have to put this out or whatever I just
want be less not being transparent for
me you know Angie she agreed she was
like okay let's do it and then that's
why I gave her her time or whatever just
really think you know and all that other
stuff like it it was nerve-wracking and
then she was being you know transparent
on she wanted to be transparent it
really just gave me like you know
thoughts that like you know what I
didn't think this is the right way of
doing it so then I have my own beauty
channel and I was like you know how
minute I need advice for meeting my fans
so I don't know what to do they're
telling them like my reservations and I
don't really know what I wanted
yeah so your I mean your audience is
really like strapped in for the ride
with you guys like that's pretty bunkers
but also very beautiful they pay
attention like they give us a lot of
advice yeah what's there what's the
audience like interaction like what's
the feedback that you've gotten from
posting those videos oh my god amazing
support like out of thousands and
thousands of comments you know maybe it
would be like one or two people saying
something stupid like yeah whether it's
like just dumb stuff you know like easy
big boy stuff like that you know but
it's most of it has been just so
supportive and we we've even gotten so
many emails and DM talking about how we
helped people to stand in their true yes
their love for somebody or what I ran
out like what that's that's really cool
and I like that you're so honest about
like taking your time and like thinking
through everything and being really
respectful of each other and not having
to like force straight to like now we're
in a relationship and Lullaby here we go
you doing all the relationship tag
things
it's decide he's just like if you're
dating somebody it's just like oh you go
on a date niggles great are you
girlfriend and boyfriend no you got it
you don't fill it out in that aspect you
know what I'm saying so
yeah and I mean and what a time to do it
I mean the world is a very crazy place
so we're all rooting for love in any
capacity ranges I had a lot to do with
it who must be to get in like this
quarantine I'm like yeah I mean that
could go a totally different way you
guys could get on each other's nerves
and it went the opposite direction so
that's very cool so you guys have been
busy developing you know relationship
you've also released an e-book during
quarantine why not tell me about this
for people that don't know yeah so it's
called mastering our social media and
basically it's funny because a lot of
people thought because we drop ya around
we drop don't look like maybe a week
before you out shirt you like confess
your feelings really what people thought
they had to do with each other and it's
like it doesn't I know I mean but
basically with them but we are telling
our audience you know and people who
want to market themselves on social
media whether it's other people who want
to be influencers or businesses or
whatever the case may be the steps that
we took to get to where we are and we
cover Facebook Instagram no YouTube yeah
we talked a little bit about Twitter and
like song as well but it's those major
platforms and basically how to monetize
it like how to create a buzz like oh
yeah that's awesome
what's the what do you think is the main
key from the book or the main like piece
of advice that you guys would give the
main piece of advice what I'll give it
to them a little teaser that makes them
want to read the book where Caesar is
you know I have one I don't want to say
that but with our book it was just like
what I was telling you earlier earlier
it was like I found my passion and I
stuck with that you know I knew what my
audience when it's the sea so do
something that you love you don't have
Sam but also figure out your audience
like she was saying swear it's not all
over the place you know if you're
talented and you don't make it fun
videos you talented playing a piano you
know stick to it people are gonna love
it
find make it away towards entertaining
enough so people actually stay with you
and watching you know saying well stick
with that and then capitalize off of
your audience you know engage with them
and stuff like that so you can you can
really build on that you know exactly
and we also you know the
that when people because we've been
asked up before they look something that
would make people wanna buy the book
we also have worksheets at the bathroom
that it's not that we just throw all
this information at them in the mirror
what do I do with this because a lot of
people might not know we actually have
multiple worksheets helping them like
teaching them how to just identify their
brand breaking down like how to create a
brand in your vision we also have quotes
from humans making bad a start like
everyone we have some great quotes of
advice and stuff and we put content
calendars like we put so much work into
this book and on top of it we wanted to
create a book so where it wasn't like
let's just make money off this Hornsea
and release a book and give them like
the general be consistent it was like I
know let's break down how I became
successful how you became successful and
put it in a way that it can it can help
the audience understand understanding
from a you know a ten year old through
eight year old to read this book and
it's like everybody still gets it it's
not so much information to where you're
feeling you read a history book but it's
time a little it's not just a little bit
of information once I came they didn't
give us you know I think that's great
because you know working online is such
a weird like amorphous kind of thing
that no one knows exactly what the
guidelines or what like the blueprint
looks like and so to be able to like put
it in a tangible form that's like here
this worked for us take or leave
whatever works for you and then go for
yeah I also think it's so true about
finding something that works for you
because your joy and your passion for it
comes through and watching people like
work joyously is exactly it's so fun to
do and I think I think you guys do a
really great job balancing because like
you said you talk about LGBT it's stuff
but you you don't get so heavy-handed in
it like you find the funny moments and
you keep it light sometimes and you go
deep and it's like a nice balance I
think it's for everyone what do you
think what's the biggest misconception
that people have for you guys in the
work that you do online
[Music]
what do you think the biggest I know I
know in general there's like you know
between traditional entertainment and
like social media digital stuff there's
always a little bit of like you know new
media internet stuff isn't as legit as
you know it's like just in saying like I
guess the answer like that like people
think I feel like but that was also the
mindset I would say like two years ago
then again because even now traditional
entertainment traditional actors are
trying to come over to this innit like
what is someone this you keep stuff you
see all kayakers on you see Will Smith
yeah he's like ah you know what's miss
you and he's been transitioned like I
want to be too I want to start doing
funny videos you know it's like we are
obviously doing something right and it's
like these were the big actors for the
TV stars to want to know what's up with
our world and come over here it's like
we're we're the new television you know
yeah and I still do think though even
though there has been a lot of progress
in the mentality of you know the
industry and stuff looking at digital
media I think that there are still
people who probably the masses that
don't understand like how this is
structured like a real job you can you
know not everyone's of course is
structured like a real job but anyone
that you see that is extremely
successful it's not by accident I think
that they think that you know success
comes overnight to people and stuff and
you I don't think you really understand
that saying until you have to try and go
get success on your own and that's you
talk about that a lot in the book too
about how it's true it's very structured
it's not just oh it looks this fun and
like oh my god you get to post videos no
it's not just that it's very demanding
and you have to be your own boss to be
successful yeah and even just an example
like like the whole love story that was
a
two percent real but I still had a
business mindset it's like oh I could
put all this in one video but you know
what let me keep them here you know what
I'm saying give them something to look
forward to you know what I'm saying when
you're watching a show it's not they're
not gonna give you the whole show in one
play you know you gotta you still have
to have that business mindset to words
like all right like we got to be smart
about it because like you were saying to
there you could just have a viral moment
and you don't know how to turn it into
be successful right you know yeah
totally know uh what are your biggest
pet peeves about each other
being so close there's got to be
something that acts you about the other
one my biggest pet peeve is honestly you
wouldn't even expect it nobody would
think like what is that and you know but
Natalie literally being in my house all
the time you need being at her house all
the time
what's she's doing anything when the
kitchen was she doing anything like in
the bathroom she doesn't close the
cabinet's I don't get it he wouldn't
expect to be it but she doesn't close
cabinets she'll cook I have one two
three four five eight nine nine cabinets
you season and that was open I don't
know why I'm just weird but I get though
yeah I get it
I'm always trying to be happy you know
and I feel like that annoys her
sometimes when it's like even when she's
like you got to be annoying
well I'm just always happy sometimes and
I'm just like oh my god dang
we don't know I would say it does bother
me that she can be like we're both clean
but sometimes she just like to me I call
it like Nikki I'm like okay like okay my
sandals aren't in the corner I'm sorry
but those are still very sweet pet
peeves how do you know in a creative
sense when you guys are coming up with
video ideas and coming up with like
collaborative ideas how does that work
for you do you just kind of like sit
down present an idea to talk it out do
you just put a camera on and figure it
out later
I think one more someone it's like a
challenge it's like okay how can we do
this challenge you know how can we make
it entertaining and it's just like and
keep the audience engaged so we sit down
and think about like I'm just thinking
about one of my favorite ones that we
did was just like giving back me we went
to a Hollywood and she had a money suit
on and it was just I want to give back
well it has to be entertaining people
get mad all the time but we want people
to stick around you know so she was in a
whole money suit we went or glued money
everywhere on her and it was like yo
let's just ask people like trick
questions and you attribute they get it
right like let's just give money so we
have like what dollar bills i dollars
how what might how much you want to go
for is how hard the questioning yeah but
we do we do when it comes to those kind
of videos like the challenges you know
I've ulnar both moments those just
happen but as far as the challenges we
definitely clean them out and stuff like
that but if it's a prank towards each
other I definitely have to be my own
plenty because we're always together -
right oh it's like how are we supposed
to do with this we're in the same house
you know them say it's like all right
let me call mom you know try to do all
of this you know so but it's really fun
it's really cool and I love it and but
that is like the planning process when
it comes like challenges and give back
and you know the raw emotion that just
happens you know that's well there's
something for everyone with you guys
okay we're gonna take one last break
when we get back
have a couple more questions for you so
we'll be right back
[Music]
did you know that there's a company
that's mastered the science of sparkle
meat light box lab grown diamonds they
hacked a billion-year process to grow
stunning lab-grown diamond stones in
about two weeks and they're some of the
highest quality stones that exist
they're always near colorless always vs
clarity always a very good cut and
always eight hundred dollars per carat
they come in three colors to white blush
pink and soft blue after they're grown
in the lab they're transformed into
gorgeous lab-grown diamond jewelry it's
Beauty meets brain go to lightbox
jewelry dot-com slash Grace and use code
grace for twenty five dollars off that's
lightbox jewelry dot-com slash grace use
code grace for twenty five dollars off
too deep do you have a bunch of stuff
laying around the house that you don't
use you probably definitely do and we've
all had the time to just stare at it and
wonder how and why it got into our
locations to begin with I'm talking
about like kids old baseball gloves or
those jeans that you were once or never
wore and you had high hopes for but now
they're in the back of the closet or
like a phone that's in a drawer
somewhere we all have a phone drawer
well there's an app that you can use to
sell all this stuff it's called Macari
Macari is the selling app that makes it
fast and easy to sell almost anything
it's super simple you just take a couple
pictures of your stuff you add a
description and bam your item is listed
and once it's sold Macari emails you a
shipping label and you just stick it on
and send it off there's no meetups
there's no hassles and with millions of
people using the Macario app in all 50
states your stuff will really sell and
the app has over 600,000 reviews on the
App Store with an average 4.8 star
rating so why not give it a try super
easy
no meetups no hassles and you can get
rid of all that stuff that makes you go
why every time you look around don't let
that stuff you don't use go to
sell or buy almost anything on my car
you can find Macari on the App Store's
or armored car e.com that's em ER ciear
hi Macari the selling app okay now I'm
gonna ask you ladies the two questions I
ask every single guest that is on the
podcast and the first is who alive or
dead would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at it's a very important
question it's very you know it's it's it
reflects a lot of the societal issues
it's a it's very dear to my heart and
this is an answer that can obviously
change on daily basis but who in this
moment today alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
cold spaghetti okay okay wait I don't
want to say dead I wouldn't do dead I
wouldn't do that I don't have to okay
alright so alive I would just do battle
Trump yeah yep that's a good answer
don't worry it's a very popular answer
and it makes a lot of sense yeah well I
guess I wouldn't call it cold you dang
doesn't have to be a person no it can be
it can be a it can be whatever you want
okay because I would throw like multiple
goals of spaghetti at the server ona
virus that's fantastic we haven't had
that answer yet so that's perfect okay
the other question asked every single
guest is to tell us your worst pants
shooting story or like a close call
bathroom scenario but you can only use
three words or three small phrases so
for example mine is college jogging
front lawn Hey and this is like you said
a bathroom experience right like a
bathroom emergency something like that
that stands out
okay he said three words yay three words
are like small phrases whatever works
for you okay okay pede uh-huh okay peed
in the bed three now you could do that
but is what damn is four okay peed in
bed Natalie okay no follow-up questions
mine would be Elementary okay
diarrhea school bus okay before we get
to the very end of the podcast cuz we're
reaching the end and we want to give you
a gift for being here I have to know I
have to know what's what's next for you
guys you're doing videos you have your
channel now your book is out and
currently still available for people to
purchase right yeah okay so what else is
going on what's in the works that you
can either tease that or mention you
know we want to work on more like media
like the book and stuff like that you
may we're thinking about doing something
exciting for our audience I don't want
to say too much but something exciting
for our audience you're thinking about
even like books or something like yeah
like yeah because the cells are doing so
good that once the coronavirus is over
maybe we could do like some type of tour
like that yeah and we also are working
on producing like more shows because
we've a show called the scholarship
that's on these networks and we want to
create a movie out of the scholarship so
yeah I was gonna say this time you are
trending all right
he is that we've had for a while I put
them on the big screen or shopping them
to like my pigeon of pitching them to
like Netflix Hulu everywhere you know
what I'm saying and actually Florentine
has been you know we had a lot of time
as well so it is just like definitely
how can we get this stuff out there
absolutely Koba 19 and stuff to these
big networks you know cool well that's
so exciting I'm waiting for you I'm very
excited to see what happens next
now before we wrap up completely usually
when we do the podcast in person we have
a personalized fortune cookie that we
give to our guests but we have now a
virtual fortune cookie that I believe
melissa is emailing to you guys if
they're able to receive it okay so my
fortune is if you whisper into this
fortune cookie your surprise for easiest
birthday we promise there's a chance
somebody might not hear so tell us what
it came and this will this is old then
then this is for next year if you have
already planning I feel like you guys
are so far in advance on your plans for
things that you muster and have next
year so it's supposed to only in the
fortune cookie or to remind you remind
him mine is here we go
a message from old easy to young easy
please fix crime climate I like this
debate alright climb Knicks climates
means okay fine a message from all easy
to young jeezy
please fix climate change this is high
key
stressful you have a lot of work to do
fixing climate change for all of us
before we sign off where can everyone
find you guys and everything that you're
up to if they don't already know okay so
you guys don't know make sure you guys
go to our YouTube easy X Natalie and
subscribe there that's where all of our
joint you know collaborations are and
you know where we talk about our book
and do pranks challenge is everything
gonna easy exam that's our Instagram
together as well and my Instagram is
young easy
y ou u mg easy and the mine is and
naturally period Odell and then we both
have our individual YouTube's - Natalie
O'Dell yep and then yeah all of our
social medias are the same sweater
amazing the artist social media invest
in yourself you know we're trying to
build a army entire bunch for new yes
yes thank you ladies so much it was so
fun please guys go check out everything
that they're up to you can watch their
love story the friendship story read the
book get ready to see them on TV and in
movies it's so exciting I can't wait to
see what you guys get into this year
thanks again for being here and we'll
see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye too deep
tody codeine not too deep cry static not
too deep is a production of grace Helbig
incorporated producer Melissa Deamonte
edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]